سوق الساعات الفاخره المستعمله سيتفوق على
الساعات الجديده في غضون عقد من الزمان
ووفقا لبلومبركس سيصل هذا السوق الى 85
مليار دولار في عام
2033 وهو اكثر بثلاثه اضعاف ما تسمى بيعه
خلال العام الماضي روليكس ولاول مره قرر
الدخول ميدان بيع السلعه المستعمله حيث
اطلقت برنامج معتمدا
لوكا مسبقا في الست دول اوروبيه خطوه
روليكس جاءت في ديسمبر الماضي بعد ما
انخفضت اسعار الساعات بشكل حاد بسبب زياده
العرض مع استمرار انخفاض الطلاق الشركه
السويسريه تريد السيطره على السوق وتقول
انها تريد عبر هذه الخطوه ضمانه اصاله
الساعات بيعها من قبل بائعين رسميا لكن
رولكس تواجهم منافسه مع تجار ساعاتها
المستعمله الذين قد يصطارون الى خفض
باسعارهم للمنافسه والمزاحه
[موسيقى]
هل يشكل سوق السلع الفاخره المستعمله فرصه
ام تهديد العلامات الفاخره
هو يعني مثل ما نقول سلاح ذو حدين
بالتاكيد هو يمكن للسلع المحلات مثل رولكس
مثل ما راينا في المقدمه انه دخلت على هذه
السوق هي تريد تستفاد من الشريحه الجديده
اللي تكونت مؤخرا يعني مثل ما قلته
بالمقدمه انه هناك شبح ازمه اقتصاديه بس
هي مش بس شبح اسماء اقتصاديه الان هي
الترند الجديده
انا همم اعيد استعمال اشياء وادير بالي
على البيئه نوع من الايدي او الهويه خصوصا
اللي همم الجنريشن
اللي هي همم زيت الالفيه فصار هذا الجزء
من الترند او الحركه فاليوم بتقول لك
رولكس اوكي ما هذا السوق بره يعني مثل ما
شفنا هيضعف ثلاث مرات ال 85 مليار مثلا طب
انا استفيد ليش تيجي سرت بارتي يجي وياخذ
هذه الفلوس بتصير المبيعات مش الكل قادر
على دفع طبعا اللي يقدر يشتري وحده جديده
هيشتري جديده بس بنفس الوقت هناك ايضا
مجموعه ثانيه لريت تشتري الاشياء اللي
تنتج القديمه اللي اصبحت نادره اليوم هذا
اللي تلعب عليه رولكس ايضا وحده هما وفاتك
فيليب يلعبون على الساعات اللي صارت نادره
اليوم وايضا مثل ما قلنا هي مساله
اليوم كمان هو جيل جديد يعني جيل عملي
اكثر صحيح
المستعمله يعني كيف بدنا انها همم مش
تقليد مثلا هي هاي المشكله اليوم
التعريف او التاكد من هذه الامور يعني همم
اليوم رولكس لعبتها صح لما هي دخلت على
السوق نفسها مثل ما سوت ارماس مثل ما
تساويش لانه همم جدا صعب وفاريت انه تميز
هاي حتى الشهادات اليوم يقلدوا لك اياها
لاكبر الشركات يقلدوها في الصين وتباع بس
هناك بعض التبس المعينه اللي ننظر الهاء
اول شيء عندك اللي مثلا المعدن مثلا
لنفترض في شنطه حقيبه كل او اكثر شيء بين
المعدن الزبر السحابه الخياط لازم تكون
جدا دقيقه المقلده بعدين في كلش حلوه هذه
هو انه المقلد هو يقلد على صوره ما عنده
الحقيقيه اغلب الاحيان جيوب اللي يحطها من
الداخل الداخل دائما مختلف فانت روحي
واختي نظره
صحيح فانت دائما روحي اخذي النظره على هذه
الحقيقه قبل ما تشتري شوفي وين شوفي
التفاصيل الداخليه مثلا على همم على
الحقائب والملابس والاستكز هذه من الامور
بس ما زال هناك العديد من النصب والاحتيال
وميزوها خصوصا السوق الثانويه